vincent on à faire une petite interview
simple un ordi view vous pensez à quoi
là je me dis merde pourquoi est ce que
je pensais échapper à ce genre de trucs
ouais vous dites quoi le matin quand
vous regardez dans le miroir je me dis
bon encore une commence en a qu à se
dire qu'on a de la chance vous auriez
aimé ressembler cliquant vous êtes les
petit petit petit à spiderman qu'est les
insultes qui vous a fait le plus mal
c'est en existait de conneries ça fait
un petit moment en ont peut-être que
c'est des trucs là que je lis en ce
moment dans la presse quand ya les gens
qui comprennent pas le film ça m'énerve
à moi j'ai vu que des bons papiers sur
le film il ya eu un truc qui m'a énervé
les gens disent il ya un mec qui a écrit
que la chine était chip et je les prie
pour moi
quand avez vous pleuré pour la dernière
fois donc vous berry ouais
dans une scène mais pour le web et pour
le voir mais sinon on devrait aller aux
jeux réponse que je veux croire dakar
il change auriez quoi en vous si vous
aviez une baguette magique un peu moins
d'ego ouais ouais bah ouais c'est vrai
qu'elle est le péché qui vous tente le
plus la luxure
ouais avec ta femme rejette qui avez
vous le plus envie d'épater
déjà moi ouais ouais
quelle est la dernière chose que vous
faites le soir avant de vous coucher une
petite brunette d'ego qui pensent 14
les gens le comprennent mal cheveux le
met il avec monica bellucci ça c'est
qu'il ya un problème énorme bassan que
pourriez-vous dire de plus négatif sur
vous qui vient de le faire
ouais bonne réponse qu'est ce que je
pourrais dire de plus négatif sur moi là
tout de suite
ouais t'es vraiment à chier dans
blueberry et vous n'êtes pas d'accord ça
me plaisait si votre vie était à refaire
vous changeriez quoi mais pour le moment
pas grand chose quand on voit beau film
votre femme c'est vrai qu'on se dit dans
le fond c'est bien fait ça vient des
problèmes dans la vie
un des points faibles des trucs c'est
bien j'ai un gros et qu'avez-vous fait
vincent que nous ne sachions pas alors
justement restons-en là ouais j'ai menti
durant cette interview bien sûr que non